bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france 1 milliards
d'euros dont pourra financer des appels
à projets pour les entreprises qui
voudraient relocaliser est-ce que c'est
suffisant alors la présentation vous
venez de faire est extrêmement bien
faite parce que il ne faudrait pas
croire que les milliards qui sont
annoncés quasiment journellement il ya
tous les jours des nouveaux milliards
qui semble s'ajouter les uns aux autres
pas du tout comme votre montage l'a
montré ce milliard fait partie des 100
milliards que prévoit le gouvernement
pour relancer l'économie française et à
l'intérieur de ceux-ci il ya 30
milliards pour la transition écologique
mais qui font partie des 100 milliards
et c'est 30 milliards sont eux-mêmes
largement connecter aux 40 milliards en
faveur de l'industrie bref tout ça est
une une petite enveloppe
à l'intérieur d'une très grande
enveloppe qui elle même sera largement
en tout cas pour près de la moitié
financée par les subventions qu'ils
viendront du plan de relance européen
si celui ci est finalement validé par le
parlement et les institutions
européennes
mais donc la dernière annonce porte sur
les 3 milliards pour le financement des
petites et moyennes entreprises et le
milliard pour eux favoriser la
relocalisation mais que vaut ce milliard
par rapport aux centaines de milliards
des échanges internationaux de notre
pays
en l'absence d'une politique publique
qui mettrait un coup d'arrêt aux
stratégies des grandes firmes
multinationales qui ont fait de la
valeur pour l'actionnaire leur seul
critère de décision et de l'optimisation
fiscale le moyen d'améliorer constamment
cet objectif est donc ce qui voudrait
dire que une relocalisation véritable
une politique de relocalisation
véritable devrait pouvoir s'intégrer à
l'intérieur de la remise en cause pas à
pas des principes néolibéraux qui ont
consacré la liberté totale pour que pour
que les capitaux circulent donc temps
les capitaux circulent totalement
librement comment voulez vous remettre
en cause la fragmentation total de ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui des chaînes de
valeur
à l'échelle mondiale n'aura aucun effet
si dans le même temps on continue à
signer des traités de libre-échange
alors avec le mercosur avec le canada
avec le mexique
et puis si on continue les pourparlers
avec la malaisie avec le vietnam et
c'est donc dans ce cadre là un milliard
d'euros pour financer les appels à
projet de relocalisation n'auront aucun
effet ont pratiquement aucun effet si
justement on continue à favoriser la
multiplication de cette division
internationale du travail et qui a des
conséquences dramatiques pour
l'indépendance nationale a confirmé au
quai quelles sont les entreprises qui
sont concernés justement par cette
annonce d'un milliard d'euros le
ministre le maire a donné deux exemples
les certains médicaments notamment le
paracétamol ou certains principes actifs
des médicaments et puis la fabrication
de batteries pour les automobiles
électriques
mais vu l'ampleur de d2 ces secteurs
industriels ce milliard sera extrêmement
comparable à une goutte d'eau dans un
sens un grand vase et je pense que pour
eux pour lui donner une véritable sens
au financement de projets de
relocalisation il faut accompagner cela
il faut intégrer cela dans une politique
nouvellement totalement nouvelle en
matière de de stratégie industrielle ce
qui fait complètement défaut aujourd'hui
donc le gouvernement macron castex la
noue pratiquer une politique d' annonce
tout à fait régulière et fort bien
orchestrée mais qui ne remettent pas en
cause finalement l'intégration de
l'économie française à l'intérieur de
ces gigantesques casino industriel et
financier mondial qui ne peut que
conduire à la diminution 1 2
la souveraineté nationale 2 de la
diminution des conditions d'emploi de
travail et qui pèse aussi sûr bien sûr
l'environnement sur l'écologie donc une
politique de relocalisation pour
l'emploi justement ce que l' issue le
gouvernement se donne suffisamment les
moyens mais le pour l'instant on verra
ce que sera le plan décidé de présenter
le 25 août bien sûr mais d'ores et déjà
on n'a pas eu d'informations concernant
la réorientation de la politique
générale du gouvernement en matière
industrielle ou comme en matière
agricole est la dernière décision du
gouvernement c'est de laisser les champs
de betteraves aspergé de pesticides qui
vont à nouveau perpétuer le modèle de
production dévastateur à la fois
socialement et écologiquement en matière
agricole et en matière industrielle
on n'a pas vu encore non plus de deux
mesures qui permettrait justement comme
vous le vous me le demandez comme vous
le dites qui permettrait de réenclencher
une politique en faveur de l'emploi
et alors l'emploi aujourd'hui et dès le
prêt l'un des principaux problèmes de
l'économie française mais avec la crise
due au corona virus et bien on va se
retrouver sans doute à la fin de l'année
avec entre 800 mille et un million de
demandeurs d'emplois supplémentaires et
on voit pas comment ce petit milliard
d'euros locales pour la relocalisation
permettraient de réinvestir donc cette
stratégie et du sli merci vous êtes un
maître de conférences honoraire en
économie membres des économistes
atterrés également